قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان دفاعاتها
الجويه اسقطت اربعه صواريخ هرم الامريكيه
الصنع في سماء بالجروب امس الاحد واضافت
الوزاره ان الدفاعات الجويه اعترضت ايضا
سته صواريخ هاي مارس واوروجان فيدونيس
ولوجان
صاروخيه نقاط الانتشار المؤقته لوحدات
لواء المشاه واحد 61 ولواء الدفاع
الاقليمي 1424 ومجموعه تابعه للقوات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه في مناطق جمهوريه دونيه
بتبع هذه التطورات مع ضيفنا من عمان فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه
فايزه الدويري استهدافه الروسيه ومكثف
للعاصمه كيف تقراه
الحالي القائم يعني منذ ان بدات تراجع
العمليات الارضيه بسبب فصل الشتاء
وباستثناء منطقه تحديدا
بدا
اعتماد الهجمات الصاروخيه والطائرات
المسيره لانه الاوضاع الجويه لا تؤثر
كثيرا عليها قياسا مع العمليات الارضيه
البريه خاصه العمليات المتحركه الان نتحدث
عن قذف صاروخي وقذف بطائرات شاهد
يتم تحديد اولويات الاعداء وهذه الاهداف
تتوزع بين اهداف ذات اهميه استراتيجيه
اهداف ذات اهميه عملياتيه اهداف ذات اهميه
تكتيكيه الان يتم التركيز على الاهداف ذات
الاهميه الاستراتيجيه هذه الاهداف قسم
منها يقع داخل العاصمه كيف اولا هي مركز
الثقل السياسي مركز الثقل العسكري في
المستوى الاستراتيجي غرفه العمليات
الرئيسيه ومركز الثقل المجتمعي الداعم
للاستمرار الحرب اذا ستكون اولويه في
انتقاء الاهداف لكن المستوى العملياتي على
المستوى العمليات على وجه التحديد هناك
استهداف ايضا للمقاطعات الجنوبيه
الى تفعيل انظمه الدفاع الجوي هل يبدو
قادرا الجيش الاوكراني على مواجهه هذا
التحدي المت هذا تصعيد المتزايد في ظل ما
يحتكم عليه من معدات عسكريه مما جرى
تزويده له من قبل الحلفاء
يعني اولا عمليه همم التصدي المطلق الكامل
للصواريخ والطائرات اذا استخدمت بكثافه
عاليه ليس بالممكن لا لاوكرانيا ولا
لغيرها هناك ما يسمى مبدا عمليه اجهاد او
انههاك او اعماء الدفاعات الجويه بحيث يتم
ارسال العديد من الطائرات الحديث عن 20
طائره في كيف هذه العشرين طائره تسبب ما
يسمى الاجهاد والاناءك والاعماء لماذا
لانه الدفاعات الجويه هي اعداد محدوده
بقدرات محدوده باولويات استخدام محدوده
يجب ان تحدد اتجاه الصاروخ او اتجاه
الطائره ولو مبدايا او تقريبيا لتحدد
الهدف وتضع اولويه المشاغله فستخون اولويه
المشاغله ليه الاهداف التي ستهاجم اهدافا
استراتيجيه عندما يكون العدد كبير جدا
يصبح هناك تشويش وارباك في الاستخدام لهذا
السبب يتم زج اعداد كبيره من هذه الطائرات
ذات الكلفه التكلفه المنخفضه 20,000$ ليتم
التعامل معها بصواريخ تصل الى مئات الالاف
وفي بعض الحالات مليون دولار
يتم توزيع
لمزيد من تزويد اوكرانيا
وتحدث بريطانيا اليوم على وجهه تحديد لذلك
هل تبدو هذه الدول مستعده لتقديم المزيد
في ظل الاستمرار التصعيد الروسي هذه الحرب
التي اقتربت من اكمال عامها
الاول ولا يبدو انها ستنتهي قريبا
يعني
الامدادات العسكريه تخضع الى التوجهات
السياسيه والتجوال الجهات السياسيه تم
الاشاره اليها في تقريركم ان هناك تسعيدا
من كلا الجانبين اي كلا الجانبين يضغط
الاخر باتجاه حافه الهاويه الغرب يحاول
لون ليث
بوتين بوتين يحاول ان يفرز ما ما يرغب في
تحقيقه بان المفاوضات يجب ان تخضع للواقع
الميداني اذا دعيني اقول ما دامت الارادات
السياسيه
تسير بهذا الاتجاه
بالمؤكد البعد العسكري في سياق الاسراتيجي
من حيث التزويد سيسير في هذا الاتجاه لكن
هل يمكن تلبيه كافه الطلبات هنا علامه
الاستفهام الان هناك موافقه على التزويد
بمناسبه
رغم انه تم تزويد اوكرانيا بتسعه انظمه
قريبي ومشابه ودون الباتريوت لكن
سياسيا اكثر من توظيفه ميدانيا الان هذه
الحرب كما قلت سابقا تاكل الاخضر واليابس
الحرب اذا مت معضله لكلى الجانبين من حيث
المخزون
الاستراتيجي والعملياتي وبالتالي الدول
الاوروبيه تعاني بشحبه قدرات التزويد يبقى
المراهنه على الجانب الامريكي ماذا سيستمر
بالتقديم علما بان حتى الشركات الرئيسيه
للتصديع العسكري بدات ترسل اشارات ان هذه
الحرب مكلفه جدا انا انتج على سبيل المثال
10,000 صاروخ من نوع معين الاستهلاف في
العام الاستهلاك 50,000 صاروخ اذا عليها
ان تلجا الى مستودعاتها من الخط الثالث
لان الخط الثاني هو الاول يصعب المساس به
في في ظل توقعات
توتوحي بصدام قريب ما بين النيه وروسيا
فايزه تدوير الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
من عمان